good
yeah we contacted this guy earlier he
failed to stop for us at the booth he's
now at the visitor center
uh looks like the middle parking lot i'm
gonna block him in
visitor center on the parking lot you're
gonna block him in metro and nhp is that
with you
get your hands up
get your heads up now
[Applause]
[Music]
don't do it
stop or i'll shoot
the second video is from the same event
different perspective
this video is from trooper mcfadden's
in-car dash camera in the middle level
parking lot
put your hands down now
get out of the car
get out of the car now
get out of the car
get out of the car
fifty five forty four he's just brandon
trooper
this is the third video showing the same
event from trooper mcfadden's body-worn
camera from the middle level parking lot
55-44
put your hands up now
put your hands up now
get out of the car
get out of the car
get out of the car now
get out of the car
get out of the car
55 44 he's just rambling
get out of the car
trooper hernandez followed agreed to the
lower level parking lot where he struck
lagarde in an attempt to stop him the
greed then accelerated his vehicle
toward another high patrol vehicle that
arrived where shots were then fired
lagree then drove away toward the middle
level visitor center parking lot
at 7 10 a.m lagreed finally stopped his
vehicle in the visitor center parking
lot
at 7 16 a.m lagreed was extracted from
the vehicle by officers and troopers
the next set of videos will show these
series of events
this video is from trooper hernandez's
in-car dash camera from the lower level
parking lot
[Music]
vehicle and then pursue
this is trooper hernandez's body-worn
camera same event from a different
perspective
i hear noise he's trying to get out
you hear something
right behind you okay
he's trying to start it
watch out watch out
watch out
get out
get out
this is trooper mcfadden's body worn
camera from the lower level parking lot
55 44 got to stop
visitor center still
we got his vehicle parked we're uh
boxed in
get out of the car now
everybody deploy no visual
let me get right here
you hear something
5544 shots fired
get out of the car get out
get out
get out of the car
put your hands up
this final video is from sergeant
carrell's body worn camera as officers
took like read into custody
following this video they rendered
life-saving aid and apply two
tourniquets to the breed's lower
extremities to help control the bleeding
how clear is your view of his hand
you gotta shut the car off and throw the
keys out
put the car apart and turn the door off
shut the car off and throw the keys out
shut the car off
turn the car and throw the keys
then open the door right way
you can open the door handles right
there
watch you got one coming up the hill on
the other side
unlock it just unlock it put your hands
like this put your hands like this
get your shield get your shield get up
no come with me coming this way we're
gonna let's go keep your hands like this
keep your hands just like that
okay
okay just keep your hands or you can see
him just keep him just like that just
like that shot me in the middle okay
slow down slow down bro
we're gonna get you okay i'm here to get
you good i'm here to get you
get out come on come on come with me
come with me
where you shot
you're going to come towards me okay
you're going to come towards me i'm
going to put you right on the ground so
we can get something on your leg come
towards me you're okay i got you i got
you
grab it i got it
put your hands on your back go to the
ground go to the ground come on somebody
get up
gotta turn the kid on his leg
i got you the nevada high patrol
troopers and bureau of land management
officer exercise sound judgment and
courage during a pressurized and
life-threatening situation
murgree's actions threaten the safety of
our community motorists and red rock
canyon national conservation area park
visitors
officers and troopers handle this
rapidly evolving and violent situation
with extreme caution and care
i commend them as well as our
dispatchers for their professionalism
and commitment to safeguarding nevada
i would like to thank the las vegas
metropolitan police department the
bureau of land management and all first
responders for their continued support
and assistance in this investigation
public safety remains the highest
priority of the nevada state police
highway patrol division and our law
enforcement partners
thank you and drive safely